الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك سيد
الياس
ما هو تقييمك حتى الان
لذلك الهجوم المضاد وما احرزه من تقدم على
اربع بلدات ولكن على ما يبدو انها غير
استراتيجيه ولا تؤثر كثيرا في سير المعارك
حتى اللحظه
حسن من المبكر الحديث عن هجوم كبير خمسه
ايام على بدء الهجوم ثاني يوم او ثالث يوم
على اعتراف رئيس الينسكي به هناك ثلاث
جبهات اساسيه بخموت
فيليسكا
وهي في الوسط تقريبا وفي اوريكيين في
زبالوجيا اليوم هذه الانجازات تندرج من
ضمن عمليه جس النبض والاستطلاع بالنار
لمعرفه نقاط الضعف الروسيه والانتقال الى
المرحله القادمه اليوم الجيش الروسي كان
يعرف بهذا الهجوم وحضر نفسه وفي كل منطقه
لديه ثلاث مستويات من الدفاع اولا قوه
للانذار والتدمير اذا امكن المرحله
الثانيه هي الحفر الخنادق
والالغام اما المستوى الثالث او الرعيل
الثالث هو القوه الاحتياطيه للهجوم في خرق
الاوكراني للهجوم العكسي من هنا عمليه
العكس هل تقصد بان الروس سهلوا عمليه
استعاده هذه البلدات الاربعه لاستراتيجيه
مقابله لهذا الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
ليس بالتاكيد ازدهار يقال عن هذه المناطق
انها المنطقه الرماديه حيث لا يعتقد الجيش
الروسي انها مهمه ولا يعطي الجهد الاكبر
للدفاع عنها هناك محاور ونقاط اساسيه مهمه
للدخول باتجاه الجنوب او تحقيق هذا
الانجاز الشيء الجديد ازدهار هو الحلبه
الالكترونيه التي يخوضها الجيش الروسي
اثنين استعمال مكثف واكثر لسلاح الجو خاصه
الطوفات وبالتالي المدفعيه وهي امر عادي
لا اعتقد اليوم اننا نحن في مرحله مهمه
الهدف الاوكراني هو الخرق في مكان عله
تنهار الجبهات في اماكن اخرى ويبدو اليوم
انه بعد الطوفان وانهيار السد نقلت القوات
الروسيه قواتها من منطقه خرسون لتدعيم
الجبهه في الوسط وحتى في الشرق هناك جانب
اخر مهم جدا في هذا الهجوم المض السيد
الياس وهو
تقييم وضع المعدات الغربيه الاوكرانيون
يقولون انها تساعد لبل هي
الذراع الابرز في هذا الهجوم المضاد ولكن
من جانب اخر القوات الروسيه تتحدث عن
تدميرها لدبابات
لاسلحه غربيه كثيره في اثناء هذا الهجوم
المضاد ما مدى قدره الروس باسلحتهم في
استهداف فعلا هذه الدبابات وتلك الاسلحه
الاكثر تطورا في العالم والتي يستخدمها
الاوكرانيون اليوم
حسن لا يمكن قياس النجاح في هذه المرحله
دائما في مرحله الهجوم بين فريق يهاجم
وفريق يدافع وكان استعد لهذه المرحله
الخسائر ستكون كبيره دائما لانه نعرف ان
المهاجم الريشو بين ثلاث مهاجمين لمدافع
واحد وهذا امر مهم تفوق التكنولوجيا
الغربيه في الدبابات هو في التقنيه
المستعمله التكنولوجيا المستعمله خاصه في
امكانيه الرمي في الرمي على مسافات بعيده
وسرعه الرميه والاهم حسن هو القتال الليلي
والتي هي مجهزه فيه هذا لا يعني ان لن
يكون هناك خسائر ولكن انا اعتقد يوم هذا
الخرق او البريتش كما يقال بالانجليزيه لم
يحصل حتى الان نحن في مرحله البروبينج
مرحله جس النبض
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت
شكرا جزيلا لك